it's great to welcome back to the
program today billshare contributor to
the Washington monthly Politico and Real
Clear Politics also host of The History
Podcast when America worked Bill always
great to have you on and we're welcoming
your dog today as well yes if you can
see in the corner here Nova is chewing
on some plastic yes hopefully they'll
hopefully they'll keep her occupied
let's hope so
um so let's let's just start with the
outlook for the next two years I mean uh
interesting Wall Street Journal op-ed
yesterday about Republicans uh being too
dimwitted to really wield the power that
they're going to have and how they're
fighting over McCarthy and it's just
kind of becoming a mess of course
Republicans will narrowly control the
house they will not control the Senate
it looked like the Senate would be 51-49
and it sort of is although Kirsten
Cinema now says she's going to be an
independent but seemingly will not
dramatically change how she plans to
vote I think maybe although I'm not
completely sure about that so like what
is anything going to happen in the next
two years legislatively that is
significant I mean you know me David I'm
a fairly optimistic person but I you
know you know I'm saying my expectations
very very low for this Congress I mean
if they can keep the lights on and if
when I get default you know
congratulations yeah this still works
um if there is a utility for 24 for each
party from what does or doesn't happen
over the next two years it seems clear
that Republicans are going to want to
make the case in 24 that repo that
Democrats didn't get anything done in
this two-year period and that things got
worse that may be by their own doing of
course as often is in politics is that
the type of thing that is likely to
swing a presidential election like the
one we would see in 24 a sort of
referendum on what Democrats got done
when they held one of two houses and had
Joe Biden in the white house or is that
just not likely to be a very impactful
um argument uh two years 23 months from
now well generally speaking you know
assuming Biden runs is the nominee yes
uh you would assume that 2024 would be a
referendum on him I mean that's
typically how re-elections go and
something that I talked about over the
course of the past year midterms are not
really referendums on the president
that's a bit of a misnomer uh and uh and
I think that has been borne out in this
pastor because the new Biden's approval
was not good
uh but you know midterms
uh I mean this is not you know a settled
argument but there is an argument that I
I've embraced that they're about balance
and an elector is trying to balance
things out from the past selection and
kind of keep things roughly in the
middle uh which is why the opposition
probably tends to do well
irrespective of presidential approval uh
and that didn't happen this time
I would argue because the balancing
Choice was the Democrats because
Republicans put up candidates who were
essentially imbalanced and were doing
disruptive things and that spooked that
spooked much of the electorate uh and it
speaks to a uh an intra-party conflict
with Republicans Mitch McConnell whom
Democrats looked at as you know
obstructionist extraordinaire
had a different take on how to handle
Joe Biden in the past two years which
was let's have a modicum of cooperation
let's I hate shutdown shutdowns always
make us look bad let's let's do the bare
minimum let's do the infrastructure
let's do the semiconductor Investments
to compete with China let's partner on
Ukraine and we can fight Democrats on a
bunch of other things where we think
they're going too far to the left
and the Trump forces didn't subscribe to
that they were mad at McConnell for
being as Cooperative as he was they put
up a slightest set of candidates who
were totally out to lunch who were
caught up on Election denial and other
culture War type things and that gave
room for the Democrats to say look we're
trying to keep things on the on the
street and narrow here uh and these
people want to you know uh you know
break all the China uh so now you're
going into a congress where again you
know Mitch McConnell can't dictate what
the party strategy is because you have
this narrowly controlled house uh
although I should I should caveat here
we don't even know who the speaker's
going to be correct uh so you know if
it's McCarthy Kevin McCarthy and if
Kevin McCarthy is beholden to the far
right then you have this open question
can you keep the lights on can you avoid
a government shutdown can you raise a
debt limit to avoid a global economic
destroying debt default that becomes a
big unknown uh if the anti-mccarthy
faction makes it impossible for
MacArthur to get the 218 he needs
there's this threat from the moderate
Splinter faction of the Republican Party
led by you know Don Bacon at least Don
Bacon's the one who's been most vocal
about this saying if these guys push
push us too far we'll partner with
Democrats and put up a bipartisan
speaker be a Republican
but someone who's not beholden to the
far far right and if that's the case
then maybe we're open for business then
maybe we actually can pass a few things
and maybe makana would be willing to do
some bare minimum stuff again so
Republicans don't seem like they're
insane
on the uh Kirsten Cinema situation
um there's basically every analysis
under under the sun this was done and
timed in a way just to upset Democrats
which doesn't seem to I mean it seems
strategically like it leaves a little
something to be desired in terms of an
explanation there's the Arizona
explanation which is Cinema was facing
um a challenge from a progressive
Democrat by becoming an independent
she's able to short-circuit that
possibility and maybe uh turn it into a
three-way race in which the incumbent
independent easily wins re-election in
Arizona that that's another possibility
three is she just really wants attention
and when it's 51 to 49 the way to get
attention back is to at least threaten
that maybe it's actually 50 50 again
what what's your best assessment of the
timing and the decision
uh you know I'm someone who has uh
defended Cinema over the course of the
past years she's arguably the most
effective legislature the Democrats have
had I know the the counter argument is
well she you know kneecapped their dream
agenda so don't give her credit for
passing something smaller uh but part of
that argument was that it was impossible
to get the 60 on things you could
McConnell wouldn't let you get the 60 on
infrastructure or gun safety or the
Electoral account act or what have you
and that proved not to be true Cinema
was the person uh doing those deals
actually doing the negotiations and
finding the common ground so I think she
deserves credit for that uh and I think
she has taken away the wrong lesson
from that experience uh she was able to
do what she did because she could Bank
on 50 Democrats right for whatever
compromise she hashed out because there
was an intrinsic you know I mean you
know parties tend to be favorable to
their incumbents uh assuming they're
going to be the nominees that Arizona's
a closely divided State you can't a
Democrat can't guarantee to win a
Statewide election there uh if she is
your best bet you you will go along with
her on her deals in hopes that she keep
keeps that see for Democrats now
maybe she's not me she she won't be the
Democratic nominee uh maybe Democrats
can put up a nominee that can be
competitive in a three or three-way race
and so it push Democrats in an awkward
position with her and so her deals I
mean the Challenger before was
convincing ten Republicans this is in
your interest you know it is better for
you to do this infrastructure deal or do
this gun safety deal then it is not we I
know we're going to fight on Election
Day but you'll be in a worse position if
you fight me on this which is hard
enough but she did that now she has to
fight a two-front war
to pass any kind of deal and mind you
wouldn't even know what kind of
situation the house is going to be in if
it's going to be hospitable to deals her
political value is I'm the person that
gets things done if she's no longer that
person
then she has a harder argument to make
and and so I I if I was advising her a
month ago I'd say you know what why
don't you wait and see what happens with
the speaker's rates right why don't you
wait and see if you can get a couple
more deals under your belt for let's say
why don't you do a little Outreach to
the Democrats in Arizona and say hey
look this is where my thinking's at I
mean there are other Democrats that
break ranks from time to time and to
have nearly as much uh upset with the
base as soon as Arizona because she
hasn't done that Outreach and and so I
hate to play you know armchairs
psychologists with this stuff
but you look at the recent uh reporting
that the Washington Post did on this
which suggests that this was sort of in
the making for a long time uh and I just
kind of come down to I just think she I
don't want the attention argument
because
she doesn't do a lot of media I think
she does a lot of things that don't
attract attention uh but I do think she
likes being a party of one she likes
following her own Compass she doesn't
like having to play the footsie with the
elements in the basement don't get what
she's doing and so she made a decision
that's comfortable for her but I don't
necessarily think is the right strategy
both legislatively and politically I am
no Cinema fan by by any means but I do
find interesting that for a while now
there have been a lot of people saying
Cinema shouldn't be in the Democratic
party because she's not really a
Democrat you hear sometimes the same the
same thing about Joe manchin the people
who didn't want her to be a Democrat
have sort of won in the sense that now
she isn't a Democrat but now they're
still mad and there's some there's like
something interesting about that but as
I've said before you know when people
talk about you got a primary Joe manchin
with a progressive if a progressive
defeats Joe manchin in a primary in West
Virginia
I don't see any way that that
Progressive wins I think that that seat
becomes a republican seat Arizona's
Dynamics are different than West
Virginia and an actual bona fide
three-way race is a very different
situation than Mansion being primaried
by a progressive but there is some state
level strategy here that is at least a
little more connected to reality than
the West Virginia Mansion thing it seems
to me well I I
yeah yes yes and no I mean obviously
Arizona's not as red as West Virginia is
yeah uh now progressives have challenged
mansion and primaries Mansion Stomps
them yes goes on to win
um look Arizona
if it's blue it is just barely blue
uh even this past election look them
Democrats managed to win governor and
Senate but not house right uh the house
popular vote was Republican and even if
you make some s because there are a
couple uncontested races even you use
some estimates there Republicans would
still have an edge in the popular vote
you know Republicans put up truly insane
candidates for a swing state and got
burned if they learned their lesson and
put up you know center-right candidates
you can't count on any old Democrat
holding on to any seat in Arizona uh so
the notion that I mean yes Cinemas
numbers are bad
and I think she did things
that I I think her issue set is
perfectly fine for Arizona I think her
legislative success is excellent for
Arizona I think the optic she's chosen
to do along with that have been terrible
and someone self-sabotaging uh and so it
puts her in a precarious position but if
you get Ruben Gallego or Greg Stanton uh
uh and that person can get you know 30 I
mean a three race is just such a jump
ball yeah because you have no idea first
you have no idea are you gonna carry a
lake or a Doug deucey type on the
Republican side that's a huge difference
uh and we really don't know you can't
look at a poll today and really know how
much the son of a pull from the Republic
from the center right in the center left
uh I mean I wouldn't be optimistic about
it to be honest because you look at the
races where Independents have won uh
typically speaking one Party's candidate
just tanks right make it easier for the
Independent to pick up the line share of
of one party's votes there are a couple
of ones I'm aware of where an
independent one with credible Republican
Democratic candidates uh one is Angus
King in May when he when he ran uh and
he won that Governor's race by a hair uh
and then when he ran for Senate it was
much easier for him but he just but
you're talking getting in the upper 30s
to win that kind of race the other way
is just even Torah governor of Minnesota
when I know a little bit more about the
fascinating about the Jesse Ventura race
is the main reason why he won was
same-day registration right 70 of his
vote was same day registrates and who
were they 20 something white male
wrestling fans like it's not a it's not
a typical kind of race that you can
model anything else after so you know
Cinema is is uh in Houston Credit case
because she's an incumbent
uh and I'm not saying she can't pull it
off but it's a real roll of the dice uh
and I I would say I think you could do
better mending some fences with your
Democratic base so you can win that
primary it's very unusual to lose a
primary if you're a synonym coming so I
think with a little little elbow grease
she could have done that uh it made her
life easier but obviously she's made her
choices well I don't really make
predictions but I will predict that uh
Cinemas fate will not be to be in Baja
California off the grid surfing and
doing conspiracy theories Like Jesse
Ventura ended up after his uh
gubernatorial run uh Bill share
contributor to Washington monthly
Politico real clear politics and also
host of The History Podcast when America
worked Bill always a pleasure having you
on all right same here take care happy
holidays